what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
a kevin samuels videos ladies hate it
when
the rules are reversed before i start do
not forget
to subscribe to the channel and ring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be notified of my daily
videos while you're at it follow my
instagram guys um it's just pearly
things with a z
the link is in the description um i'm
trying to get 10
000 followers on instagram and i'm going
to become more active on there so feel
free to follow me i'm going to be
posting stuff like my fitness journey
stuff like that but okay i'm about to
start
good evening hi how are you i'm doing
well how are you
good what do you got for me um i just
have a question i'm newly single
and one of my girlfriends she sent she
actually sent me this live so i would
she was like you should check in and see
what he had to say for you okay um you
know
i've seen a few of your postings and
things and
i consider myself a professional i'm i'm
in social work
i'm going for my master's and going to
get licensed and things
but i'm open to you know dating people
who don't have degrees and
and i'm i think i'm a pretty good
communicator but my my question is that
i think i'm just having a lot of a lot
of issues finding
someone in coving you know going out on
dates
is it's a hard thing and also kind of
meeting people
are you were you married no i wasn't
married but
um was in a long-term relationship okay
how long was that four years and when
did it end
back in the summer so i would say of
august
okay and it's it's difficult for what
just to meet men meet men who are
serious you know that really
aren't just trying to you know have sex
for one
initially and just because my thing is
about being friends first and building
friendships and
you know how comfortable they are how do
you
how old am i oh 29.
so you do that not having sex
partying why why why did that come up
um because it's just something i'm not
i'm not there yet i guess in it i don't
want to say i'm not there i'm just not
there
what do you mean maybe if you meet
somebody that you're comfortable with
initially
and then boom things happen but that's
not a i guess it's not a focus
okay um well men want to have sex
well definitely so what does that mean
i mean you i i key on things like that
what do you mean you want
how long would you wait how long should
you have to wait
i don't think there should be a time
frame on it and today's conversation
gonna have to ask
okay okay so you're asking for help so
i'm gonna need some information
oh well go ahead ask actually i've
already asked information
huh okay how long i don't have a time
frame
okay i'm asked again how long when i'm
ready
i mean that can be any any time it could
be when you meet somebody
but about how long so you say how long
is yeah how long you start dating
somebody how long before you have sex
i guess to just throw it out there i
don't know
how long that's my question i don't know
i mean that's my
how long okay see
you want me to just go ahead and take
their time and just go
indeterminate and you're not even
willing to put a possible time frame on
it
oh i think we need a time okay the
person that sent me this video
um has heard my thoughts i'm like
waiting before you have sex
and i i do think that's fair for a guy
to ask how long it
will be i don't have a problem with that
anything well now we need to we need a
cooperative woman
we need a woman that understands what
men want and understand
that yes this is going to be a part of
it and i've asked you the question
how many times so what do you want me to
tell you if you're not willing to answer
a question
it's not a trick to it you're a grown
woman yeah
that makes sense i mean i'm i'm learning
still learning about different
personalities it's not different
personalities
it's the a lot of you ladies tend to
want men to do all the work
you want somebody to go through the
trouble to get to know you and peel back
down
and talk to you and discern them no i
asked you a simple question you know
well i'm just curious don't want men
want to get to know the women that they
date
because in my opinion that's why a lot
of men end up in
situations with in marriages and
relationships with women
that are wretched you know because she
has a pretty face and they didn't
take the time to get to know her before
they started sleeping with her
wouldn't even answer why
so what i don't know isn't it answering
i mean no it's not
not not you're not 19 you're almost 30.
yeah
not a little girl you're a woman
definitely
though it's not it's not a trick
question
it's not like sex is like taboo and i'm
asking you
you beat somebody you like and you date
them how long approximately before you
have sex and you say well whenever
then don't be upset if nobody wants to
date you
okay your fault
well i mean i'm not upset but thank you
i appreciate your feedback
yeah thanks
any other point is that you have outside
of sex
uh sex wasn't the only pointer but if if
you're not willing to answer what's
important to men
men are not going to be willing to date
you
got it see what i'm showing
you folks is women you want an unfair
exchange
all right i mean that that that's a
different perspective of things and a
good way to look at it i guess
how about this how about this let me
give you a different perspective
let's do it your way and
just whenever whenever whenever the
moves right okay
yeah so here's how you do this you
pay for all the dates okay you do all
the driving
you do all the planning you're in charge
until all that and then after you decide
you want to have sex then he could step
in and start paying for the dates and
driving and everything else
but until then it's all on you to do all
the investment
is it bad i know people are gonna say
cap
but i wouldn't
i wouldn't really care to be honest like
i don't
see a problem with not wanting to spend
money when you're just first getting to
know somebody
all the courting of the follow-up all
the other stuff would you be willing to
date it being
like that
um it would depend because
well to give you a straightforward
answer then didn't know if you look at
it from that respect yeah yeah
of course because you would not want to
just be stuck on the hook
dating with no idea of where this is
going whether or not you're going to get
something that you wanted
and have to put all that effort
yeah and i'm not talking about this one
man i'm talking about all means if all
me and got together
and sent your picture out across the
world everybody knew no one goes out
with her she has to pay
would you not do that though why not i
mean you're still trying to get to know
a guy right
i mean exactly i mean but but i mean
that's also considering if
if that's the things that i'm doing if
i'm allowing that person to
to pay for everything and to do that no
no not in this world
because i've asked you the question just
about generally how long
and you didn't like that so i'm like let
me switch it to something you can
understand
you don't have to have sex but as long
as it's
not on the table you're responsible for
paying for all the dates yes arranging
all the dates
about the dates you're you're in the
man's position yes
and would you be willing to date men
if you had to do that
i mean then no i wouldn't be exactly so
don't expect me to date you
okay okay but okay okay
i see i see i got you i i i understand
things from from that perspective you
see you see what i mean some of your
likes were thinking
ladies you see what you listen ladies
you see what i mean thinking
you're just trying to get her that no no
no ladies understand
you want men to do our part but you
don't even want to even
broach possibly even i just asked a
general time frame
i didn't say ironclad see what he wanted
to say three months six months 30 days
whatever but then flip it you're not
willing to just do an open-ended
financial
responsibility coming out of your pocket
well i'm i guess for me again and this
is going to be for anyone you know
because i i i get your angle
again i'm respected but it's
pretty straight forward i'm just gonna
say i'm gonna say one last thing and i'm
gonna let somebody get a chance
but i guess in this world especially
you know for me so question for the guys
would you be cool with getting
to know a girl for say six months if
there was no money and courting involved
if you guys just took the time to get to
know each other no money no courting
just curious everybody has a different
perspective everybody comes from
different walks of life
okay for personally i won't let somebody
do that much for me unless i'm coming
halfway
and that's just that's just me
everybody's not everybody's not
comfortable with that and i
i do i feel like i hold up my and see
let me let me explain something to you
let me explain so let me explain
something okay go ahead
you wanting to come and pay halfway
don't mean nothing to us
because our time is more important that
you'll have the money okay
that's that's that's honest do you guys
not care about getting to know a girl at
all
like especially if you're vetting for a
girlfriend or a wife
i don't know just in my head it would
make sense to get to know them first
so well you know i'm not that kind of
woman [ __ ] i
i'm gonna pay my half they're offering
to pay half
like this is something like that's
something like there's some [ __ ] we
don't give a damn about half we don't
care about
because what y'all pay half on ain't
nothing pay half on the goddamn mortgage
and the car notes and everything else
all the way through life then we talking
yeah but until then we talk about half
on some dates
half once and things happen but but you
know what i don't want to go on a date
where you paying half and i'm paying
half where the end is gonna end up in a
hug
i'd rather pay a hundred percent to get
laid
[Applause]
you can hear me that's why your ass
gonna win go ahead
that was funny um i'm trying to think of
what my thoughts are on that
i don't know i really see the value in
getting to know somebody before
you sleep with them i think it helps men
and women
um even though men like typically i
don't think see that right away
because i've just seen a lot of guys be
blinded by a girl because she looks a
certain way and i think
that when you start sleeping with
someone men and women
tend to both get it more attached
obviously women
more but i don't know i'm sure you guys
will let me know where you disagree
in the comments um don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification
bell that way you're going to be
notified of my daily videos and i will
talk to you guys
next time